a 14-point lead and Robinson fires up
the three-pointer barely grazes the rim
Martin saves it right to out of bile
back up top stolen by Jeff Green and
needing a stop defensively Michael
Malone chooses to take out Nicola Jokers
because he has those five fouls and the
small lineup gets it done
and brown wisely just taking his time
the deflated crowd has watched Denver
with a huge fourth quarter Brown puts it
in Gross brown 21 points Off the Bench
11 here in the fourth quarter
a 17-point lead as we come down to a
minute remaining
and a whistle and a foul
he is absolutely delivered when they
needed him most
hear the little step side step three
they've just he's just given them great
production
[Music]
and jokic
as happy for others success as he is for
his own
the buy where the free throws Brown by
the way a second round pick as we
mentioned earlier played his college
ball here at Miami
his first year in Denver signing that
two-year free agent deal how about this
ridiculous finish
use the rim as a shield eliminates the
shot blocking ability of bam